at hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
he did he yeah why is his mouth though
he's open haha he's just a mouth
breather
he definitely the unique fella man he
jumped on that notorious b.i.g would not
let go
yeah nah just that one night he let go
but not like Big Poppa definitely dude
we got it poppin yeah bro
I think what's poppin right now is that
Saints Jersey they do things man who the
twelve-year-old in me wants it so bad
magical team bro oh yeah they're magical
very magical dude the Ruff said this are
real --gel it's a real that's the
authentic yeah at least has some juries
when I was young if some kid he would
just spray-paint like his number on the
one kid just they wrote one of the Dave
maggot he wrote on his son's back some
man hell yeah Dave made it from the New
York giant
it into his son's back with like I'm not
a knife but like a something kind of
sharp all kind of tatted a Dave make it
yeah oh wow it's a Dave maggot for the
next like 15 years of his life no number
11 - and I don't know did make it was
number 11 key look that I don't think so
I thought he's number I thought he's in
the 20s that right you think Dave maggot
I forget dude that's old school also
you'll be careful saying Megan I feel
like I'll slip up there you know I
didn't say megger nope didn't say that
either dude I just say Megan - that's an
old school reference what Dave Megan
yeah hell yeah he when he played it he's
53 now he was 5-7 returned the kicks
he's number 30
there's five four wasn't he fine with
him he also had some it uh hit some
crime and either criminal history any
yeah as eyes yeah crazy eyes no he
didn't I study it crazy a 30-year prison
sentence do you know he's a mystical in
the NFL Dave yes man what did he go away
give me the [ __ ] ball dude you know
gotta go to job 30 years jail robbing a
part-time student what you call happen
to dude this guy's awesome yeah
he could by work for us dude you know he
could look the culture corner could get
real interesting bringing Dave Meggitt
days
I know what check in fancy football
picks with Dave Baggett do you buy my
bookie if he calls in from behind bars
and gives his fantasy picks yeah
but has no idea what's going on yeah
Detroit been stupid nah man all right
all right well who else has no clue just
out of touch yeah he keeps trying to put
Troy Polamalu in everywhere Jeff Chris
McCoy yeah oh yeah oh yeah bruiser buddy
he's a bruiser just no clue try gear
contract year boy oh man I'm glad for
balls back down I love that footballs
back yeah I've been winning all my bets
and then my view yep and then my damn
Denver Broncos oh my home team I decided
to put a wager on him on a parlay five
team parlay and what has only ones that
[ __ ] it up really they're just not
good
this is not good yeah there Tara what
were some of their failures I didn't see
some of it uh I think Jon Gruden just
out coached them what we're known for
our defense chubs and he completely took
great chubs who Nick Chubb yeah
baller you know your football a little
bit huh yeah and my football dude better
than you call him Nick chubbs
what do you call Nick Chubb not child
his name is God named Khan chubbs they
do yeah oh I didn't know that yeah come
on dude yeah Broncos suck this year
though what can you do dawg
dude I found the [ __ ] candy in my
room this morning and I have never had
this candy before what time was huh it
was like a little licorice black or red
black okay now it's getting interesting
cuz it's red it's like that could happen
anyone lack certain kind of personally
yeah yeah man I got no idea how it got
there I don't know I've been thinking
about it all morning was it just like a
little nugget
yeah but I would never have black
licorice man never had licorice and not
sure it is not a rat [ __ ] huh not a not
rat [ __ ] bro if a Raskin is [ __ ] bro I'm
gonna watch it yeah
that day I know black liquors when I see
a man it's a little bit too black liquor
you're a fan of it know who I love like
liquors you do that's thing I know I
love it no one else in here like what a
sick oh wow not even cat even Jimmy
Chitwood the new camera guy doesn't like
it then camera guys say no yeah all
right black licorice hang down like that
I figure any sugar in it it's not even
candy it's just like a kind of a violent
flavor it kind of tastes like tree bark
a little bit dog it's gross
bro it tastes like those towels I have
it like a fancy gems you know they have
the towels that smell fancy they say if
you ate them no it's got like um
eucalyptus in it yes yes I love that
[ __ ] but they always just smell like
somebody's [ __ ] butt though I feel
like they don't really smell like
eucalyptus they smell like kind of like
a somebody's butt from like Vermont
mm-hmm
you know I'm saying about I feel you man
I feel but I hate licorice you notice
don't know who brought it don't like how
it got you like red licorice
that's not licorice what is it huh
that's red candy what is it red bars you
ever had you remember the Rope hundred
the red rope um do they make a black
robe no I know I'm trying buy that no
nobody's buying that [ __ ] dude so I'm
saying what are you doing man I don't
know dude I grew up different
I said eatin dark liquor hasty bettin on
the bar on the Bronco Jews I see black
licorice and we're a Dick Butkus Jersey
Oh
how many friends even the bees wouldn't
sting you back bees right now we good
like we're out of here
we good like dude it took me two hours
get here today really first I was like
mmm Ryan dude dudes have higher on the
[ __ ] highway but there ain't no fire
on the highway do you think the Bible
dude
there's definitely no fire I
screenshotted my ETA and then I was
sitting in the in the you know in the
Topanga one lane and the cop goes what's
your map sake you see me just looking at
your ass is our and 20 is not a chance
brother it's two fatalities up there two
fatalities what do you [ __ ] love that
immortal
that's what I'm saying a lot of
fictional [ __ ] dude Johnny man it was a
unicorn fight the other day at the end
of his driveway and that's why I
couldn't get get get to work on time
well that I believe Brian man my thing
was is I was upset about sitting in
traffic for two hours but then when they
go somebody died of it could be worse
all right man have a good day yeah that
was cool but who died no he didn't say
oh he didn't know they should send a
picture back card a car you know
okay just on the back yeah this is what
we're waiting for anything you're like
older side man did you pass the prom in
California they just let anybody drive
to anybody dude what do you mean do you
let anybody be a guy with no eyes dude
they got a guy out there no eyes they
pull him over
do you know what Tifa so they let him go
do you know you know what's annoying me
is how many people cry about the people
that drive tehsils and fall asleep
that's why you [ __ ] buy those things
man fall asleep in them all the time
it's their self-driving people what a
rat nod I'm like look at this
[ __ ] the highway it's like
that's why I bought the goddamn thing so
he can snooze in traffic we did yeah
that's my pride but it is but no you can
of traffic well he's gonna be there all
the time apparently cuz he's [ __ ] late
cuz of all the [ __ ] fires on the
cement remember that one time he said
there was a flood he did save me this
once eh I'm like that's the ocean hey
maybe the ocean - you're right sir yeah
you [ __ ] and it's not coming for you
he said there's a flood coming for me
like it's a [ __ ] ocean dude that's
always been there your delinquent you
and your chubby buddy that it's dark
licorice Christ dude dude you're looking
thin
really yes noisy I don't think so yeah I
think it is just this Jersey been
thought you been working out now I've
been doing a little bit of yoga what
else man now usually trying to look like
meg Ryan or what's your point here
you know you slowly transition I got a
couple rise like why stealing like
background kind of guy that wants
balloons at his funeral
[Laughter]
you get stoked around a Halloween
because their own egos oh sweet meg Ryan
costume just dress itself whatever man
you look like you look like the worst
band member of Limp Bizkit yeah limps
home they call me no you do look thinner
dude I'm just saying you mean yeah maybe
you're getting fatter dude you know I'm
not about fatter dude I've been on this
diet now for seven weeks they really
yeah since I've been in a while yeah
drink eat oh dude nobody's noticing that
well I beg to differ everyone's tell me
today I was like no yeah they did really
yeah who did everybody any more sad Wow
yeah yeah why don't you name sweet red
again you [ __ ] know you know what
you're talking about you know what the
[ __ ] you tell me you said name in colors
a cheetah
green blue cheese and there's cuz you
rhyme it doesn't make it funny or real
dude dude you named Chester cheese yeah
you're mine you're like the edible cat
I'm like your [ __ ] done dude I'm in
this town dude you're done in this
shitty town support the podcast here's
an ad
I'm just saying bro dude and I'm just
saying to you 66% of men start to lose
their hair by 35 and her mind starting
to thin out huh it's so funny I was
thing about that the other day really
yep I don't take any kiss huh thinking
how thick it is no thinking about how
thinning out it is
oh wow are you starting to see a little
bit of your head
I'm sure to grow back dude but not if
you don't take care of it how can I take
care of it though
I'll tell you how man for hims calm it's
a one-stop shop for hair loss losing
hair missing hair who's got your hair
for ya yeah calm bro no snake oil pills
no gas station counter someone's we're
talking real prescription solutions
backed by the science yep no more
awkward in-person doctor visits it comes
straight to your door discreet all you
do is answer a few quick questions a
doctor peeps it out send you exactly
what you need right to your don't get
your dumb thick and get the hair loss
treatment everyone is talking about
featured in GQ Men's Health Esquire and
playboy named a few King and the sting
Lister's can get started with hims
complete hair kit for just five dollars
today right now while supplies last my
listeners can get started with the hems
complete hair kit just five dollars
today right now see the website for full
details go to four hems calm / k 80s for
hems calm / Katz
yup that's fo r hims calm / k 80s get
that hair up time to buy few more pants
dude I'm on that keto diet last night I
got me some EF Chang Chang you're on
that ito dive are you've been eating
yeah I've been eating impressed I was
like food your mom digs it so I've been
getting the lettuce wraps and I get soup
from PF Changs at 11:00 p.m. last night
all the moms embed by 8:00 p.m. so
you're wrong woman made that up
but I will say this post mates can be
your personal food delivery service if
you're a thicket II thought like old
Brandon over here it has grocery
delivery whatever kind of delivery
service you want all year round 24 hours
a day 365 days a year no more trips to
the store all you do is download it to
your phone fluff free for a limited time
you guys the Kingston listeners Post
mates is giving you guys $100 a free
delivery credit for your first seven
days yep if you want a little cut a carp
at 4 a.m. or you want some egg rolls at
about 2
about 2:00 p.m. they got it for a
limited time postmates is giving our
listeners $100 a free delivery credit
for your first 7 days anything you need
anytime you need it postmates to
download the post mates and save with
the code k ATS 2019
yup that's K ATS 2 0 1 9 for $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app get
thick someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit what up boys
without died you want to start up a
little debate club if you want Derek
what's up what's up Derek huh oh not
much just chillin dude alright first we
got Nathan Gunther
this is Nathan big Gunnar straight out
the boot bad there's Louisiana got a
debate club for y'all who's the better
serial killer Jason Voorhees or Freddy
Krueger if you're asking me I'm going
Freddy all the way because I mean he
there's not a time that he can't get you
you always have to sleep so uh plus
Jason scared water I mean all I have to
do is [ __ ] jump into a river
I think I'm strong swimmers so I'm going
Freddy Kreuger all the way let me know
what you guys think gang gang buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz young man go tiger so
definitely Freddy Krueger I stuff a
Freddy Krueger Nightmare Before Elm
Street poster yeah that doesn't mean
here doesn't mean that I grew up a huge
fan so I'm definitely did a defend
Freddy Krueger yeah you get that ball
skin he looked like you some ball sacks
covered skin here the shitty skin yeah
but you guys in a fire thing you may not
asleep son you could not sleep Jason
does it run only walks right well he's
fast lazy I'm not I'm not gonna say any
stereotypes you should swim yeah okay
okay Jason and you dress alike first of
all onesie shitty weird accouterments
all the time axe hockey mask you know I
could easily see you wearing some of
that junk I've seen you wear a Freddy
Krueger sweatshirt before it was autumn
all right well I'm saying this who is
definitely I would go jason voorhees
dude because first of all the guy um
could he played goalie played college
goalie first of all people even know
that about one ball so you gotta say
right there he's an athlete dude in some
of his early work he would put people in
he would pick people up in a sleeping
bag and beat him against a tree bro
stronger I'll give you that he was
strong he was strong I Dre rather run
from Fredrik in my dreams then [ __ ]
be laying in a sleeping bag and just
know it any minutes a man could close it
up and [ __ ] use me to tenderize an
elm dude here's the thing Jason's just a
regular dude who's pissed off at the
world Freddie's like a straight-up
monsters he hides in your dreams please
know he's everywhere bro he's not if
you're awake Inu and [ __ ] no he pops up
when you're awake too well what is that
that's cheating dude how you gonna go to
sleep huh how you ever gonna sleep you
could do money Never Sleeps bro you know
what I'm saying
grind bro you know what I'm sayin stay
awake dude you know drive around the
fires by your house hustle cash tag
inspo yeah keep it goin bro
what I'm saying is though Jason Vorhees
you could throw an ax from 200 yards and
hit somebody hit a receiver dude hit my
Kevin's or [ __ ] hit some [ __ ]
running from in the woods here's the
thing okay I just jump in the water his
dumb ass can't swim yeah but an axe can
swim you the link went dude what about
that what's had a fast shark that's a
[ __ ] axe boy you're dead all right
I'd Freddie all day yes fans say 54%
Jason oh you free don't touch me keep
touching we don't touch me remove your
sweatshirt on don't touch me with all
the burns on your hands from the fire
you had to drive through up next we got
Brandon Bayer oh I got nipples could you
melt me [ __ ]
I got a debate question for you guys
today you get in a fight and you [ __ ]
your nose up you can see my sense going
off to the right get face surgery or
just leave it
game game buzz buzz buzz buzz dude you
don't [ __ ] with the nose you don't mess
with the nose it changed your look for
the rest of your life
you look like [ __ ] Val Kilmer you
seen Val Kilmer lately it's tough dude
it's tough
your boys had some snow surgeries you've
gotta leave that [ __ ] also no one wants
your boys who's my boy you see your boys
call me sir I'm your boy you had some oh
yeah to reconstructive nose surgery you
had to nose job dude not Hollywood nose
jobs reconstructive nose jobs matter of
fact I've been taught I'm talking about
getting you a deal on one really yes
that's just taking a little bit off blue
later brah you need a two-car garages
you want me to breathe around if your
nose is broken dude you know pray on it
I think what about them what about a
Breathe Right strip look pretty cool
yeah but if they almost get a really
like rope to kind of hold it over
against one a year to really you know
you'd have to almost uh lock it into and
the problem is when dudes touch their
face they all look exactly the same
you've had to nose jobs dude not like
what he's going for though he's going
forward the looks nose it seems like
what he broke his nose would you get it
for broken nose shattered - this guy
why bother 101 because you got a [ __ ]
up notes
dude the guy's shitty tattoos this could
be you Hey rewind it let me see how bad
as noses it's not bad not even looked
like there's an issue just septums on
got a debate question for you guys today
you're getting a fight you [ __ ] your
nose up you can see my shins going off
to the right if there's a surgery DEP
them I just leave it Gang Gang buzz buzz
gang for a face surgery let me say
looked up like this I'm see yours that
left nostril that left nostril could fit
a grape in bro I put a grape in it yeah
I know yeah small one yeah nothing
frozen is out huh oh dude here bro do
you can put mail in there dawg
like this is the number 10 really
yeah because one of better and small
this one's large yeah well my nose is
any owner Ava isn't even on center did
you break it
huh no there's just like something
inside like there's like some bad scar
tissue inside that kind of pulls it from
the inside
um I don't know probably childhood
violence you know I don't know but the
man went in there they tried to they cut
they tried to cut some of it out but
some of us stayed in there oh damn so
cuz I remember for like two days my nose
was kind of it was straight and then it
s just grew back or whatever and I was
like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] crazy
but this guy dude I think you're fine
but I think first of all I don't think
got a problem yeah I don't think you
need a shirt I don't think you need a
nose job I don't think you need anything
maybe your nurse David you got a fog in
you got a tattoo what is that it a burn
no it's a snake it's two snakes oh you
got two snakes I was thinking the same
thing yeah you're fine are you going to
heaven dude so I would chill out man I
pull over and get some rest I think
honestly yeah you look pretty tired I'm
super white teeth I'd get more tattoos
and still say [ __ ] the nose here the
nose dude dude yeah if you get another
tattoo nobody then it fits yes you know
I think you give a broken nose and you
keep it you got to have like six tattoos
to offset it that's why so many tattoos
my face looks like [ __ ] distraction
distraction the art distraction damn
yeah something like holy [ __ ] who I'm
looking at for a while yeah this morning
I'm like oh cool meg Ryan that's cool
what else do you hide 62% of people went
with never touch your face ever Wow it's
what you do it's a dangerous road why I
agree with that but also is people like
not everybody can even afford to touch
their face yeah so it's like I think
it's something have to do when you're
young probably you think you know you
know Oh fix your nose you're talking
about like face surgery yeah if you're
gonna get Rican a reconstructive surgery
what do they do in your community Kat
they really don't do it till there
except their eyes they'll write cat eyes
yeah every now and then you'll see an
asian girl or guy with a nose job but
and they paint their eyes on her head
and close their eyes exactly when you
say you can't drive like that huh
no you shouldn't
well if you have a Tesla yeah yeah have
money that's really the answer to
everything
Asian girls get their lips done lips get
more so now yeah Wow I like that [ __ ] do
you
I'm not mad at what else they get done
mmm a lot of Asian girls get liposuction
get the fat like put elsewhere oh yeah
uh more of them are getting what is that
called gentrification mmm yeah and some
places I'd say butt jobs are a little
more common now usually boob jobs are
the biggest ones you know thin asian
girls yeah yeah cuz you have flat asses
and big fake tits they did yeah that's
crazy
it is yeah how can you even stand up or
something if somebody gives you from the
back you're going down that's the no
that's the way they like it yeah
somebody hits you in a spit ball on the
back and you [ __ ] going you get a go
down a flight of stairs that's crazy
it's crazy dude watching some girl was
trying to balance her tits on her chest
all day
that's insane we had a girl like that in
school her tits were so big it was like
if she actually stood up she would just
fall completely face but they were real
though right we like in male real to
like Bailey's almost they were like two
alcoholic bellies on her chest I don't
want to give away the girl the last name
her name was Daniel will call her Daniel
J she had the biggest Maddie's you've
ever seen but were in seventh grade that
is looking at seventh grade you
pedophiles awesome I was also in seventh
grade
dude it's such a distraction I it's a
curse for that poor girl bro she had
some melted John in seventh grade dude
breasts or nipples you know I'm talking
about fat titties see oh oh
and they were so distracting she'd wear
overalls and just these huge Olympic
sites tits man oh yeah
seventh grade like high here's Michael
what did you do earth science and you
got [ __ ] tits McGee over here he's a
gay bro that's Jupiter and Saturn dude
she can go anywhere
oh hey Richard you don't just stared at
her tits cuz we're why in seventh grade
oh definitely dude I remember one girl I
just couldn't even talk to her tits were
so big if I would go near I'll just
vomit and be erect at the same time bro
that sounds cool yeah what is that
called action when your vomit Nevin
erect
at the same time he looked that up it's
an urban dictionary is it yeah I think
it's called like a um what is that right
Bob its function
oh yeah that's a warning time for a Tata
sponsor yet they called it something
different like the like I don't know
what they called it have to think about
what it was embarrassing huh
I don't think so it's because I was just
vomiting with no erection yeah weakling
yeah well or you could just not vomit
and just get a boner in your pants like
every other seventh grader dude yeah are
you huh twenty-seven dude you're the one
who is trying to look at seventh-grade
girls tits I was but you knew you were
gonna be older you [ __ ] you're
disgusting she was gonna grow older dude
you know with those tits anything could
happen at her bras I've been older
though she having sex too man
okay dude I'm not thinking about a
seventh grade girl having some not
either but she was getting bad that was
the rumor bro if girl has at it then
everybody thinks having sex dude I think
kid has a beard yeah if he has a
mustache right yeah Montes [ __ ] yeah
you know if he had like the child's
sideburns like dude he's gonna stick
suck yeah he's getting his dick sucked
by Betsy Ross dude dude a guy she's here
maybe I am [ __ ] yeah you don't want
to be that guy cuz you're peaking yeah
you're peaking bro you don't be that
Peaks middle school oh yeah some guy
always peaked in middle school we had
people in our middle school cuz it was
like at a certain time they and like
they grandfathered in people that have
been in school for I guess too long or
whatever sure cuz some people with a
stay in school they were like 18 and
they're just give him a job as a janitor
like all you you know you're a stick
around
yeah this year you're a janitor you know
like last year you were still in the
fifth grade but now you're a janitor
you're all out of great yeah your gym we
had this one guy mr. Larry in our class
bro he could piss over you into the
urinal when you were pissing he's an
older man huh
I mean he was a student you know I would
say he was older though that's
unacceptable
most places you know but you're trying
to keep people educated yeah but he
sounds like he's trying to piss on young
kids
mmm sometimes sudhi hit maybe two out of
maybe thirty kids that's a problem
thanks to Big Brother I never got hit uh
I [ __ ] never got hit by that dudes
pissed you don't know friggin weak boy
yeah you're right Doug what else we get
up next this is Raven Raven but we vote
on that or no we did that 62% said don't
touch the face don't touch the faces but
when you think about that that's 38%
said touch the face it would have to be
really bad to touch that face yeah this
is Raven fellas oh that's so raven got
ciose donkey on my screen that book with
Joey Diaz about to rub one out to it
I bet Brendan would do probably I have
five people to choose from but I needed
to pick narrow it down the two for you
guys anyway who's the better dancer
Chris Brown Oh baby
anyway Gang Gang what is that girl uh uh
who was I arguing with the other night
was it the comedy storm the time but you
have a me jump because it goes me you
and Ron Taylor and we were talking about
how feels got out but Duncan who we
brought in our girl would your girl but
then your opener what's his name
Aramis Ari is cuz we were arguing about
you feel doesn't have an ass he doesn't
do squats or deadlifts and it was like
now he got to the yoga nice cakes and
then are you came out with a steel
vanassa's oh yeah I've never seen it
going hi you're always hiding those
cheeks bro dude let him breathe my
mother age
get the cheaters out [ __ ] hater dude
yeah I know quit hiding that thing bro I
knit dude I've had back surgery because
of it there it's so hard to let I can't
lay on my back at night you got a fat
ass huh
yeah it's like laying on the hillside
everyone swore by to like yeah when I
went Theo has a flat ass Irwin what I
said you're built like a hyena and then
they're like no he's not
and then even ours I go dude I've seen
that thing in the flesh it is he said
it's like two watermelons back there why
I couldn't believe it
because I you know you're always sitting
on it around me yeah get away from me
you creep I'm just saying dude don't
hide those cheeks it's a shame it was
today for you all right well we're
getting better
we got a long trip out the back dude
that þÿÿÿ number uh yeah by inna give
them cheeks out the back bro quit hating
that [ __ ] slang garu boy you know
what I'm saying
Bernie's trying to think of something
much money can make isn't [ __ ] now
you can feel it man it's like kind of
like when a car takes a wrong turn and
goes into a cul-de-sac it comes back out
the same sound nothing I'm just kind of
here's somebody just beat on the
steering wheel a little bit this crazy
out loud the silence can be deafening
don't be mad as I want you get your
cheek out on stage dude quit thinking
about my butt you dolt man I'm just
saying
did seven adult men have an argue about
your ass the other day yeah we did well
and I lost that argument apparently bill
the thrill Clinton went to University of
Arkansas so shout out I would say I
think probably Chris Brown she wants to
know who'd win in a fight better dancer
Oh God Chris Brown all day but I wonder
about now though cuz Chris Brown I'm
sure is no have you seen great he just
dropped a new video where there's a
dying piece and they're dancing that's
just him that all really doesn't I was
dancing bunch of people but that's what
he does
well I just know he's in a lot of
lawsuits and he's probably I can't
imagine what it was gonna be like
a lot of guys just get sued so much tell
you no but nothing who is that got a
pain just had nothing he said video he's
in a lot of pain he had 40 million
dollars in his intent and he's broke now
from what go broke dude I mean how did
give his cars up yeah but what's he been
buying with 40 me bought a bunch of
stuff a bad investments he said he had a
friend who was his money manager would
see things and think he could have make
them better and he'd never made any of
them better and he just bought it that's
on you bro oh I agree it the interesting
thing about it is he doesn't seem upset
about it no he just won the masked
singer he did yep he was on there yep he
won right I know he's on it yeah he
wanted this first season
Wow so his careers looking up who's in
there
t-pain really there's just him against
himself who okay yeah that show look so
strange is it haribol looks there I'm so
bad what's your question always bet dude
Chris Brown all day I like guys sure
back in the day there's a video of them
going back and forth is there yeah but a
young Chris Brown right but yeah Chris
Brown's way better Oh Chris Brown did
this like who's better GSP or Kebede
like he learned from uh sure and then he
2.0 but uh sure are those Jays are why
do you say yes all right
he's hottest one uh sure smoother though
uh sure is like silt and what's his name
is like a [ __ ] really fast burlap
Chris Brown I'm a Chris Brown fan are
you you seem like you would be dude
underage women
dude he gets in a straight-up seventh
grade he's just gonna fisticuff with
Rihanna and she kind of won the fight
and then his career goes down the drain
she yeah but he's going back up the
drain now it's like up and down the
drain yeah it is Emerson
yeah and Rihanna is way tougher dude and
Chris Brown his yeah I'd rather fight
let's be honest all day yeah she's zero
if she yeah she's yeah she's a hitter
she's hit her she's a hit her I don't
care actually I'll tell this girl this
yeah hey Bill honestly do not give a
[ __ ] who's a better day
these dance I don't give a [ __ ] Derrick
he these are his you know he you have
more insight than you probably heard
people talk about them more in your life
than we have so let's go to the culture
corner uh Chris Brown all day Buster's
just old Menem knees the knees starting
to bang up on him you know cat who do
you like better you're younger so by
Chris Brown fan I wouldn't say I'm a
Chris Brown fan but he's definitely the
better dancer Wow Chris Brown so
talented so talented you wanted your
Chris Brown fan the hold Rihanna stuff
mmm
it's a combination of that and I think
his music just not for me
interesting he doesn't miss for me I
celebrate his old catalog he does he
have a dick how do you know I toss point
no talked about it one day and brought
him on an episode and he showed it it's
like a [ __ ] it's beautiful man most
beautiful thing I've ever seen
oh wow on some art [ __ ] not on some gay
[ __ ] awesome Jess you know well knows no
mean bro
what do you mean art [ __ ] oh that's nice
y'all some dye Colangelo [ __ ] right
sound like a game to the Klondike yeah
you might be home we're rotting bruh and
that's alright gonna sculpt it I don't
want to touch it hello see whatever you
like Doug bro clay he's a gay bro that's
where you headed and that's fine dude if
you want to be gay I don't care
burnin my big hey dude we don't know ya
dude well we know jury's still out I'm
like that seventh grade girl with big
tits I'm gonna grow older we'll see what
happened the jury's out in the courtroom
waiting for you to show back up and
accept your sentence the jury's been
sitting in their melon uh it might be me
but it might be dead cuz he said Chris
Brown has a beautiful dish he's the one
who validate for your ass jeans dude I'm
all right I believe you
yeah does he's not built like I am he
just got his girlfriend a very short
haircut by sure he shaved her head and
some and he has a girlfriend on hims
vitamins
there could be more of me theater in Old
Spice
I love Old Spice too not the gel hard
stick what else we got 51% well with
Usher
which is weird little clown my hair next
boys yeah let's get these pooches out
here first
this is rash out out first of all will
Lutz do to kick that 50 a yachtie last
night son 58 you kick a field goal do
you or a fullback this looks like
Brendan right here why is this guy have
guns and pit bulls and [ __ ] there's a
bat what do you mean dude it's just a
white guy bro she's chill dude look at
his friend as a bat and hair on his legs
that's not chill is this a proud boys
rally what's going on no this is if this
were black guys it would be just regular
guys so just assume it's a rap video
yeah but I think it's a rap video but it
looks like the guy looks like an
accountant a little bit glasses probably
no Qi have on steroids a little bit no
dude LaRoche is not as handsome as this
young you're right when you're right
you're right yeah
that dogs handsome though that does
seems like three different dogs though
yeah that's the same guys names rev five
years old 69 pounds
well is it cute look at him and his legs
he do you have four arms are just top
arms I can't tell that's just part of a
boy you'll have a full arm no he's all
thigh - yeah it's all thighs it's just
thousand feet yeah got that hourglass
figure
what yeah look as skinny as little waist
is what are you talking about that's an
animal bra yeah dudes peoples have tiny
little waist than the blob thighs it's
an animal bro
wow dude we want to survive in a [ __ ]
gated community I don't think that's
gated to the left little
you ain't killing nobody would you shoot
it and it just stapled some papers
together hey bro
will you scratch my back with that gun
and some bullets shoot my [ __ ] yourself
with that thing dude just gonna take the
afternoon off a word probably you see
yourself five times a throat and still
sing the national anthem bro that is a
weak piece dude uh-huh Mack that's
auntie Fabri yeah you right God it never
ends the other facts on this or what no
that was all we had on this big boy yeah
what are they saying just the dog he's
named Rev he's names Rev yeah that's a
cute dog he's showing off his guns
yeah well sug life what else he got
flaunt what does it roasts my wiener
what is the [ __ ] where does it show
about no idea what you didn't
relationship advice of his dog Oh God
this is from Peru this next dog is a
peruvian hairless dog from Connor oh wow
hmm oh wow very similar vibe as Theo
with the haircut for sure what kind not
that problem yeah that solve that makes
that sentence more comfortable that
makes the yeah that alleviates the the
pain the pain of what you said well
you're chose to look like Patrick Swayze
um it does he have long eyelashes was
that hair hangs enough fire Brendan
don't stalk his eyeballs I think this
dog is dead told y'all people don't even
have eyes but I get my driver's license
in California they probably will and is
this definitely dog the second half of
his body looks like a swine it does look
very piggy
it's a peruvian hairless dog that's a
dog yeah first of all in Peru
everything's bacon bro so dude I'll have
a quarter you know I'll put a little bit
of this on some [ __ ] decent bread
yeah yeah we heard you bro
why don't you even care about yourself
dude why do you say things like that
unless I take the day off you know yeah
you should have brought me the fire
surrounding your house wasn't enough of
a warning sign apparently eat this young
animals sphincter and anus bro this
thing is it said seven-month old in a
foreign country how old is it
who are you dude Gerry Epstein oh you
are this bro you think the guy who got
fired the [ __ ] conductors doing drugs
inside of Thomas the Train bro you need
help dude here's an ad from the king in
the sting
I used honey the other day but I'll tell
you right now fine oh you want to got
honey huh good for your team
Oh Miele they call it in Spain you got
honey for what honey no online are you
gonna get that you gotta stop in a sweet
shop before you press check out and
that's honey honey is uh well honey is
it's like a little thing you add into
your browser that makes sure before you
buy something good that you get the best
deal that's what it is and the other day
I was buying pizza from Papa John dude
you know and I clicked on honey before
boom save $21 dang basically free cos
probably John's about $22 so good for
you man my girl is using target and use
the honey app and we saved a bunch of
money
really yeah the average honey user saves
about
six dollars per year bro per year over
10 million people already saving with
honey so save right now honey has over a
hundred thousand five star reviews on
Google Chrome store
Time magazine calls honey basically free
money yep and it's free all you need to
do it just installs on your computer and
just two clicks click and it'll save you
money she can treat yourself to
something nice get honey for free adjoin
honey dot-com slash cats that's join
honey calm slash cats that's it get his
buzz miele going to paid abuse break on
Slim Shady break on Slim Shady
dude everyone needs a great pair of
wireless buds before you go dropping
hundreds if not thousands dollars in
each pair you need to check out the
wireless earbuds from retcon when you
say uh buds you mean putting weed
nuggets in your ear now I'm talking
about rake on earbuds the price of any
of those other wireless earbuds on the
market they sound just as good they
sound amazing
Snoop Dog cardi B brandy JR Smith
oraculum rake on see 50 watts
ear buds have totally changed the game
and their comfortable stylish oh really
yes and they look great but here's the
best thing they sound great and rate
cana offers our wireless earbuds for
everyone in a range of fun colors
unbeatable price Oh God dang go to buy
Raycom slash cats to get 15% off your
order that's by Ray con-com slash cats
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now's the time
to get amazing deal one more time by
Raycom slash pts yeah
trying to keep lights on all right boy
very easy just get me out of this
there's anybody running for office
this is Andrew asked him for some
relationship advice gang gang is that
Andrew from bleach media I don't know
what that is what's up Theo and Brandon
I've got a crazy relationship advice
question
so I recently broke up with my girl
we've been we were dating for a year and
a half and it got to the point where she
was just bringing me down all the time
telling me that I need to see a
therapist hmm telling me that I need to
read books I don't read books so I broke
up with her but the thing is so we just
try to help they'll live together for
the next couple weeks she's gonna move
out in about two weeks but my question
is I want to know for the next two weeks
is it acceptable to have a little slam
piece over I live in the basement my ex
girl lives upstairs she might not even
know if I had some little Sloot over oh
my that'd be okay would that just kind
of be pushing the boundaries at all
jhemini I fully support him I'm the
roommate and best friend
I got looks like Hilary Swank bro Buzzz
Buzzz slam slam peaches are mine did you
that big spin yeah I mean it sound like
you're stalking women on fine that was
not a dig at your buddy I think Hilary
Swank is one of the finest young men
that's ever well she she did working
baby oh dude definitely she's definitely
better than some of these oh definitely
some of the bantamweight fighters I've
seen Reese I'll take her over Vin Diesel
ye what I'm saying is first of all are
you sure you don't live with your mom
your mom might be having an erroneous
converse say a relationship daddy
also could you let's say you do have a
bunch of slam pieces vying to get into
that basement with your best friend can
you wait two weeks could you hold out
two weeks so the girlfriend doesn't have
to see it what do you mean
the other thing I don't know if I
believe you have a girlfriend I throw
that out the elf in the room it sounds
like you and your brother won't move out
it sounds like you won't move out guys
it's like a real problem yeah and first
of all yeah [ __ ] while you're indoors
cuz in two weeks you're outdoors dude
all right it doesn't sound like you guys
have a huge problem a huge plan
I didn't hear like a printing press
going on down there I didn't see anybody
I didn't see any like crafts or
mercantile area in the background no
textiles do you guys have two weeks to
get your [ __ ] together and you're
stalking people on the gram bro starting
people on the ground also called women
slammed pieces I would fix that in this
culture if I met good luck brother
but yeah I think I don't know what do
you think cat your woman I really don't
believe any of us Wow because you're
telling me the girlfriend lives upstairs
he lives in the basement with his best
friend yeah it's and you're trying to
bring a girl to the basement to [ __ ]
yeah I'm almost positive it's his mom
she wanted to read books and get it
therapy yeah dude case salty sure mom
ton make you a better person bro yeah
he's young too men oh this kids probably
13 or 14 have you ever heard the term
slam peace I have only from people who
don't get laid
yes correct yeah and I got I was in New
Jersey Ladell feel one time in the
middle of the night and uh I was at a
bars in a house there was a club and I
clubbed somebody had some zoning
loophole it was a house bar Club it was
a house bar club it was a house maybe
walking to somebody's house into a
nightclub like in a neighborhood dude
really really bizarre call the house
party people were dancing brother had a
DJ every between every song they would
stop and do the Eagles fight song oh
well and then at one point the DJ came
one I was like who wants to [ __ ] one of
these slam pigs tonight like so
slam pigs I left and what girls like
yeah I'm a slam Pig yeah so I'm gonna
jump out the window for no reason yeah
it was bad places just this was out
Manayunk before they before it got
gentrified it was a real [ __ ] d have
you heard the term slam peace slam peace
I thought my [ __ ] hulk hogan's crazy
the chick was wearing a she was wearing
a bob Brutus the barber beefcake t-shirt
as well one of the women a slam Pig yeah
wow so a slam pig so gonna be heavier
woman and they love to rest on their
area anyway you get a new jersey and PA
man people love wrestling
Springsteen all that oh good luck dude
we solve this case a little ripped my
drip we'll start with a NFL quarterback
Cameron Oh Cameron Newton yeah and you
know me man I take some fashion risk but
this is just almost unacceptable the
scarf the suzanne somers scarf is where
I draw the line uh I would even start
with this I say this man is TV so you
walked him to Goodwill and so on it hey
check this out and shot him with a gun
and just that's what came on him oh yeah
a gun will ya and it could be also that
uh he looks I call this gone with the
winds because his team is gonna take so
many [ __ ] pills this year this Cam
Newton is turning into the Dwight Howard
of football which is getting bad bro
it's getting bad he's not tough on the
field anymore he's out there laughs and
smiling I know have a good time that's
fine but you know yeah you won't be
having a good time in the playoffs man
now with that said I think that the
attire it kind of has a little bit of
like a Zorro meets sort of like a senior
citizen you think he looks like the
worst magician he looks like a
struggling magician right now they'd see
on Third Street yeah I think grandma you
see here's the problem I think the
outfit would be dope if he ditch that
stupid-ass scarf yeah it makes sense
that you in the middle of summer
Carolina short shorts the cutoff it's
the scarf them it just makes him look
ridiculous yeah the suit is actually
kind of nice man a suit yeah it makes
sense
Andy's came in I remember I was in
Charlotte one time I was eating on a
poor on him outside of a eatin area and
just a man walked by with a big with a
baby carriage and he was dressed like
wearing a bunch of [ __ ] and it was a
summertime and I thought it was a
homeless guy selling something you know
his Penn & Teller no it's Cam Newton
really yeah he was just wearing like a
big coat and he was pushing a bakers had
a real baby in it he dressed like the
goods or something he dressed like the
third Penn and Teller
they just very similar but summer style
like it makes sense if you ditch the
scarf this is pretty swaggy hand never
shuts up did you guys watched I'm in a
bad mood today
pin never shuts up you watch that
interview with Rosen he does not show
you guys is worse you know wonders but
he doesn't say anything that other guy
yeah they're like no it's just our act
no I think he's sick of your [ __ ] that
dude is a know-it-all bro I interviewed
him one time for something it was
miserable really but uh but the man yeah
I would maybe make the scarf disappear
dude so but otherwise Cam Newton fan I
think it's a bad rap he's actually
really good player
[ __ ] team no coaching no protection if
you look at his stats to a chance we'll
be Oliver there's a great coach
I don't think exactly coach good
defensive coach dude I think he's had a
lot of weapons he has McCaffrey and
Caffrey's amazing they have no line
though but they're not that bad man he
is not great the defense is great but
they're good enough for him to do better
I think you look at his stats I mean he
has some their own apps but he's a solid
player okay I'll say this he's like the
Carmelo Anthony of football that's good
that's fair what he's not a champion no
one wants to play without a chair he's
not a champion do you know the Super
Bowl if you remember though did he yeah
and lost damn he didn't win a national
championship at Auburn and here's the
other thing
he was the backup quarterback the Tim
Tebow at Florida he got kicked out of
Florida for stealing a laptop did he yep
yeah no went to Auburn but one nice
championship but I'm this scarf is what
gets me that stuff's fine I hate it yeah
that scarf is listen everything else I
can [ __ ] with matter of fact that would
like to know where he got it the scarf
is where I draw the line
yeah would you wear a hat like that ever
they ought to feel like you look cool
like with a hat like that mm-hmm no I
don't wear that type of hat Denny looked
like you saying y'all children better
close that front dough now yeah he might
be more look I'll say this in three
years he could be the toughest woman
ever to play hugging in the NFL the
Juwanna Mann
now that I would think would be dope if
he went sex change and then won a Super
Bowl gang [ __ ] bro
super gang gang sign what else you do
what else you got man okay we got a
Daniel Sal Diwani this is Daniel is was
taken out of a Bloomingdale catalog this
guy is a real person and he's doing he's
sending a bunch of different he sent in
a bunch of different things of hinges
modeling the violin different one of
your roommates Brendon first of all this
guy's way my roommate do you mean my kid
this guy's a garden yeah I could see
that your kid keeps emailing me to
Teddy's it he's not he's sick of my ship
he doesn't like the conditions at home
he said some of his exact wording dude
and there was juice stains on the email
that was like a juice box some hi-c yeah
that makes sense
yeah dude hit this turtleneck is born
the [ __ ] out what this is he's a
straight-up model though is he is he
outdoors it looks like he might be
waiting for something well the water I
think you'd be waiting for a boat or
somebody to show up is he have a friend
memory by the boat dude it's a ginger
hot summer gingers are killing it these
days is this mellow him Santino
Felder Felder Felder in-game what else
do you know this guy want from us
relationship advice why cant give me
dudes no here's a first of all he could
be bro he's very stylish first of all
bernie you don't know anything about
real styled yeah you're right you drink
a lot of your [ __ ] clothes add on one
of those places where you get the
tickets and trade him in at the counter
okay dude just cuz Drew Brees gave you a
make-a-wish Jersey and you think your
stylist today oh no I don't you sent a
picture went oh he's gonna be around
long yeah Sam well the Superbowl
don't let super all jerseys I don't
think I'm ever stylist dude but I also
don't shop at kindergarten okay so what
I'm saying is this guy obviously is
waiting for someone does he have any
more information you know did a boat
leave like I need some details yeah
maybe this guy's trying to get to
Nantucket bro you've been sending
everything he just watch I'm saying man
[ __ ] it it could be John Travolta's one
of his little side pieces that he's
ferrying in out there to Nantucket or
Narragansett or whatever and
Narragansett isn't a racial slur either
it's a tie on I think Township looks
like he's looking for Kevin Spacey I got
a lot of questions here dude it will the
water looks very calm does it say what
waterway that is no I didn't say
everywhere cific though I'd assume yeah
you think yeah cuz that's not very blue
no yeah Pacific ain't blue Pacific
nasty-looking humongous you haven't seen
a lot of the big city the size bro you
say the color the Pacific Ocean
California is not blooming all the
changes everywhere Brendan what I only
have one color - you're out of your mind
bro you have one colored oceans you're
going to hell boy yeah boys it's okay to
sting it Jesus oh god you guys are
[ __ ] idiot there's fire surrounding
your home you think oh dude there's
never a fire bro yeah your tech said Oh
big fire today on the street no fires
better really Angie boys is Angie hey
Theo Brendon it's Angie Thawne from
upstate New York with a king interesting
and that's just - depending on how you
answer maybe relationship advice
so girls who pay for meals on the first
couple of dates while you're going to
know somebody do guys find it
intimidating or do they not really care
I'm wondering because I don't want many
second dates with them and I'm really
hoping that it's them being intimidated
not that they don't like my personality
so I'm looking for a guy's perspective
let me know what you're thinking keep
doing what you're doing Gang Gang
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz girl gang
you've been a sidepiece forever what do
you did you mind people paying or what I
remember I went on a date with a guy one
time second date and she paid and I
still and then I didn't hear from her
after that and I didn't know if I was I
think let me think I didn't know if I
was how did she pay though the check
coming she was like I got this one check
came she said you got it last time oh
that's nice and so I didn't I said well
I said I think I can I said I can get it
and she goes no no I got it and I was
like oh I really feel like I should pay
for but I'm gonna let you pay for it and
then she never you never heard from him
again never woman but I don't know if
that anything new with it or not I did
she also was a West this lady had some
money so it's not like she was it
without she had she had some money I
don't know she was a baller but she had
some money and she had some money that
night I'm old school man I feel
uncomfortable for girl pays up feel
super uncomfortable especially perfectly
especially first date yeah bro what's
the next thing you know open up my door
you know I'm saying yeah no I don't want
that
strong women look like type of dude
let's the girl open the doors for you
I've been under a lot of stress recently
this to the ER I will next year I'm okay
would you let your girl pay all the time
yeah is the first date you would first
date now first date let me quit being no
let me do it but second third date your
situation say you know she's like listen
you got last time let me get this yeah
it was pretty cool then that seems no
cool but a first day of saying no no I
got no I don't need anything like oh
yeah
cat you be paying for your man yeah
every now and then I mean I don't I
don't like people paying for me a lot of
time so I don't like to eat out a lot
no you're a separatist uh no I never ate
out with this cat uh every very rarely
you don't invite her also Brendon no we
definitely do every time cat do you feel
invited or not I feel invited okay yeah
fine Brendon
oh I'd let Brendon know if I did
feel my true good I feel like you file
charges against Brendan where we gonna
say Gary puts on a wig and both Gelfand
in a class action against Brendan okay
and I'll get a section ends I'll get a
nose job and turn it into a set of tits
on my face and I'll join the class
action you'll worry about the class
action the twink who sells your merch
all the time we're gonna get this pig
pay money that's all a dollar a day in
torque to sell your shirts oh yeah who
else went to therapy yeah here's his
cheeks out you won't get yours out dude
you want sell more shirts I'm getting my
butt out Brendan dude I want to see you
I don't use my body to sell stuff like
you do yeah you okay wrap myself in
cheap gold and children's trinkets to
sell [ __ ] other people yeah okay
I'll sell regular man their own Jersey
uh what were you saying okay yeah sorry
cat before this guy interrupted you no
problem
first dates depending on who asks you
out to go eat I think it is cool when
the guy pays for the first day and then
girl picks up the second one but if I
asked a guy to go out to eat I don't
automatically think that he's gonna pay
I invited him out interesting whereas I
think girls are more likely to pay for
meals after the first date if they don't
want to see you again could they don't
want to feel like they owe you any
twisted yeah a lot of good she did you
for dinner and drinks and now she feels
like I owe him something like he
deserves to get laid after this so we'll
just pay for the bill and not that's
what she did to you she was sick your
[ __ ] already
was like I'll pay I don't remember I'm
gonna file text or maybe you know see if
I can get in touch with her and ask her
I could have been it she's just saying I
don't want to deal with this it's a
first date it's in the ground I don't
mind if I take you out and then you pay
for like ice cream at the end of the
night or maybe want to address a round
of drinks just to show like I'm just
here for the food and drinks you know
yeah I think if a girl pays for the
first date it's a little emasculating to
the guys especially if he's offering
it's kind of a whole move well I think
but though a lot of these ladies they
the feminists they say they want to pay
for it all and then want to pay for
everything you
a man like me yeah they're all single
stop being a guy you'll probably find
one yeah yeah
that's what I say good luck girl you
gotta be team I don't think it's a
personality but quit [ __ ] Alphen
these dudes yeah quit a in these DS up
next we got Brock this is our boy Bryan
gang boy rock what's up Bri Oh what's up
finding my name's Brock I'm here in
Sacramento California
a huge fan of you guys thank you so much
for the podcast it is absolutely [ __ ]
awesome I had a little King it or sting
it for you guys today my question is
what are your thoughts on webbed toes oh
hell yeah where's the web at in the
middle easier mmm
bang bang good good right here dude all
right there okay oh they're just stuck
together on he drew a little dotted line
yeah did I'm a fan of webbed toes I wish
I had some I'd swim better it makes you
unique I did a kick a ball harder fat
farther i doesn't michael phelps have
webbed toes i don't we problem I think
it's way I think only has one big leg
like it is ready bag zipper man um does
he have whip those size join it mm-hmm
get out of the water cheating dude 6 and
same facts about my oh that makes his
feet flippers cuz you can dis oh look
images of Michael Phelps web toast yeah
I knew you had WEP no way yeah cheater
get the images out Derek that can't be
not real I'm pretty sure he is like 1 2
web toes but imma [ __ ] is a freak there
they are
that's better that's a corn that one you
ever had a corner bunion you know I've
worked on a farm though we had corn Milo
Otis let's zoom cotton Wow look at that
yeah easy to swim you [ __ ] aren't even
aren't even supposed to be on the land
she's born like that dude yeah fish when
you're freaking cousins a salamander
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] dude look at him
it's not a but what is that it's not an
adult male that is a water that's a
dolphin human yeah it's a water man look
at that
Wow super flexible we got big his hands
are got we get the quads on that fish
dude I would yeah you could easily make
a nice fillet out of that man's leg if
I'm in a plane crash and that dudes in
there too I mean him like a sword first
[ __ ] first do before the gun even sounds
I'm [ __ ] God no flounder yeah she'll
floundered oh yes Jesus Christ I'll eat
them I'm all about webbed feet make sure
you knee can swim like a [ __ ]
it's conversation starter I think this
man I think this I think you just have
to be careful because you could almost
be giving Satan a head start brother you
know what I mean your your you know your
hat your you know Dark Arts on the feet
you're 5% in a witchcraft rather people
see that at the beach or they see that
at the pool basically the Witch of 2019
yeah you can't be tying a dreamcatcher
to the back in truck and just cruising
around town you don't know yeah yeah you
should get a stable job and then uh it
out that's all I'm saying is balance it
out there's nothing wrong with you but
the way people perceive you is gonna be
really could be a bit hectic can you
wear sandals huh
probably not here you can I have sandals
on right now you know enough is oh god
your feet what's wrong with your
neighbor my father speed freak you're
gonna head feet up in Denver dude
400,000 feet good luck with your feet
man Kenya a couple pieces of beef jerky
at the end of your legs boy you ain't
got nothing on these sirloin hitters
daddy look at that what is that nothing
ooh ooh do they spin in swamp water just
to keep it under water friend bro these
are 40% Spanish small son Oh what's up
dog yeah hey don't hit all the buttons
that's one this is Ethan and Andrew
Clark this is Ethan and Andrew boys oh
they're over there Missouri
you know Table Rock Brandon Bo gang gang
buzz buzz it's me and Ethan here in the
middle sounds like someone's Sarge
Algonquin Park PA in central Ontario
Norfolk true Oh
close though it's Canada so Tanner
stated camping we saw a bear today hey I
was and he said hard corn it's hard for
me bro shoutout to the Algonquin nation
dude first of all those our native
forefathers dude talking about native
North Americans native Canadians yeah we
stole their land well we lost some of it
dude and they also gave a lot of it up
for sugar and liquor yeah that's one
input up very good fight um the whole
would die again I need the terms here
dude what's hardcore no blankets kill
what you kill what you eat you know I'm
saying yeah that ain't for me ain't that
dude really now I'll be a little rowing
side piece if he wants to kill [ __ ] and
then make fires I can hang on his back a
little wood yeah a little outdoor
thought while he's [ __ ] killing the
deer I'm just working the background
with that finished John wood around yeah
I love that bark together for no reason
at all do we really need that whatever
burn is over there making wine out of
berries and stuff in a barrel the edge
of the disk off the edge of the fire
dude I think this man Canada beautiful
okay it's gonna be the next in America a
lot of people are ahead in there already
read our article the other day about a
lot of people moving to Canada hmm and I
think obviously the woods get them while
they last brother and if you want to do
some hardcore camping you and your buddy
get out there with a couple of knives
and see who falls asleep first you know
that's an old-school deal man I like it
two men enter one man leaves you know I
like battle to the death of nature yeah
and also it's brave to be out there in
Jason Voorhees hunting ground brothers
his ground yeah have you been a camp in
the like shade up camping yeah yeah I
mean Campbell East came us out of the
post office do we used to camp outside
of the mall in our town we would go
there for the
on Saturday like your hand out overnight
in a tent and then go Sunday oh you got
a camo like you'd like stay in sleeping
Dick's Sporting Goods camping we'd sleep
in a tent outside and then go back to
the mall the second day I'm always about
20 miles away from us any one big
campers in there I grew up in Denver so
we used to camp all the time I hated it
uh cat I'm sure no my parents left
Vietnam so we'll never have to camp
again there you go but you guys were
right camping that's living yeah we were
living yeah but living in Vietnam is
almost like camping in some areas I mean
there's more it's certainly more of a
survival element bamboo dee you don't
look like a camper out in the back you
broke em bro have you ever camp boy what
I'm not but you never camp before I mean
if you don't camp you don't care but I
mean they look for the Underground
Railroad that's not good yeah a little
more a little survival camp outside for
the New Jordans
suddenly a lot of life you will camping
outside a foot marker have a lot of
black outdoorsmen huh no that's not our
thing man
we like it in the gym we keep it right
in the gym
you made the opposite a camping you mean
keep it in doubt indoors
Oh
Derrick's never sleeping on a treadmill
that's it boys mmm that's it for today
well dude we did it man Billy I'm seen
in a while dude you say that every week
Brendan do I miss you man
say something else that sounds real I
didn't see last week and he's talking
about your ass cheeks I'm gonna be good
see oh man I did see you last week
oh we did do we do oh that's right you
hate us we did two episodes that's right
dude now look at us now we're still here
yeah dude that was like 70 ads in this
yeah right
Shane's going the Super Bowl you know
what's funny is uh four teams that
really showed out Patriots chief Saints
Rams
they're pretty well Titan Titans they
way we look struggle City yeah where's
your team huh they'll get better there
we start off slow I love sailing they
always start slow yes they never win oh
stop slow their middles typically slow
as well and in the end they just don't
think yeah it's different yeah end is
near that's what I think that's what I
think there's a lot of good teams though
brother um there are a lot of good teams
man what you got dates coming up I got
some uh let's see this comes out boom
boom I'm in Denver this week I'm in
Denver say the whole town I wish I was
there every week you say that ever I
could camp home town Denver
comedy words Demerol five children
muscled out Thursday Friday Saturday
Connery works at Denver now after that
first week of October I'm in Pittsburgh
and second week I'm in Philly get your
tickets T fat K perhaps we can talk to
her here in Pittsburgh yeah
what date the first through the third
are you there - yeah be the first
through the third I think I 3rd through
the 5th Thursday Friday Saturday why
what's up either - you trying to be some
Terrible Towels
black game yellow black and yellow I
might be in Pittsburgh for what on the
fifth are you doing show up there maybe
oh do you should wear that Jersey the
Pittsburgh Steelers game so I can get
watching it stomped out dude I went to a
game at Heinz Field Saints for a
Steelers it was awesome and it was where
he said this running back he set like
their all-time rushing for Steelers he
said like their all-time now it was
before that no before him or might have
been after the bus it was like Willie
some some little guy think they called
him wheels or something
this dude was some little somewhat
darker guy but he was um
Cleveland I'll be in ten eight to ten
thirteen I believe that I'll be in
Cleveland Indianapolis Grand Rapids
Detroit Madison and Milwaukee
so just rescheduling shows rescheduled
shows and that's it that's it buzz buzz
gang gang
[Music]
the king
[Music]